don't mean are you gonna spank me in
Irish oh what a spank you so hard
calling I'm gonna spank you as hard as I
can from a wearing lead young age I've
always been curious about the world of
professional phone sex so today I roped
in two of my co-workers to join me on my
quest for sexual enlightenment
have you ever fondled yourself on the
phone with someone Wow I've ever had
phone sex before yes of course no I've
never followed myself Wow
- on the phone - guide us on this erotic
expedition I brought in phone sex
veteran Mena desaad I mean it decide my
vanilla job is managing small hospitals
and a few private medical facilities as
my personal side job I am a foam fantasy
artist and I say phone fantasy artist is
because you are building a story and
you're being a storyteller based on your
listings you could be anything from
being a woman of color that's black a
gentleman barely legal 1819 ish hi I'm
Kimberly Hayley I'm packing things up
and I had to break up with my boyfriend
because he's going school out in East
Coast and I feel so lonely right now in
my new dorm space and I can actually
sound like a real cold [ __ ] they'll
make it go on the floor and stuff my
shoes for fun it's all about the collar
men voices take off the tin on your
voice deep and down and come from the
stomach it's all about making them your
fan the more that you're found the more
they'll call the more longer they will
keep on the lines and longer they're on
the lines the more money you get I love
it through and there look I'm gonna come
you like not yet daddy net exactly we
have one of Mina's top clients on the
phone ready for you right now okay hey
are you serious
no no we're gonna throw you in off the
deep end
this is a real person actually he was an
actor I hired but they didn't need to
know that all you gotta do is call in
read from the script make sure you're
pushing them to their sexual limit all
right you understand
I understand if you're not getting an
erection out here you're not doing it
right all right oh hello caller how are
you how are you doing today what do you
like to do to me I want whatever you
want well tell me tell me about like
what what are the things you like I like
to be naked with you in the jungle what
are we doing in the jungle I love the
jungle I can tell you I can tell you
that's a pot of rain there's a pot of
gold at the end of the rainbow describe
oh do you like all the green all the
trees all around this top of the morning
to you
we're gonna get you to be I'm gonna get
you all undress into clovers and then
we're gonna spank you to to some sexy
time it's just meaningless jungle baby
yeah I'm gonna put you in a little trap
Pat I'm gonna put you in little boots as
well
do you like that do you like the Thunder
coming through the trees I can try Oh
little laddie
he's been very naughty oh my god was so
good I am going to spank you and thank
you I would not be doing this
particularly form of art for almost 20
years if I did not think it was fun
fulfilling and entertaining
I do it because I enjoy my callers I do
it because I love helping other people
in their kinks best caller I love being
a phone sex artist as some ways day
being a phone fantasy specialist is
something I will probably do for another
20 years
[Music]
little buddy
he's a very naughty occasions of the
rainbow illusion